previously on the walking dead I got
another good one for
holy [ __ ] you know why you stopped
bringing more mouths to feed was a good
idea holy [ __ ] here's what would happen
if that does it it's nah you come back
no matter how you die
Wow gum right I need to do a little
intro here really quick if you were with
me this morning you would know that I
replayed all the story to get Carly back
Carly you could choose between Carly or
Doug or whatever and they did it work
and then I gave it another try and I'm
fixed some files and eventually my story
continued and a lot of people were like
why do you care so much if Carly or a
client it's kryla dog if my choices
doesn't go through each episode then
what's the point of playing this game I
mean that's the point of the story
nevertheless Carly's here now she has a
purple vest nevertheless nice yes whoa
lady relax strangers just around my
brother we we just want to know if y'all
can help us out
that's right Carly you tell them
yeah I know you're outnumbered here just
turn around and go back yeah that's
right that's fine but but you'd really
be helping out a fellow survivor part
with some extra gas before we leave you
ain't getting no you need gas
Harry place is protected by an electric
fence generators provide the electricity
our generators run on gas yeah we own a
dairy farm a few miles up the road
y'all be willing to lower your guns and
just about some kind of tree
how y'all doing on food trust anyone
with that hair yeah plenty at the dairy
we're pretty [ __ ] actually when it
comes to food Lee why don't you and Mark
check the place out see if it's legit
I'm going with you I got your back if
anything seems fishy all right cool so
uh what are you all thinking
I think No No Deal we'll just there oh
uh what should I choose rise why should
I choose I don't know I think they will
be boring over there
well this chill here I think we'll stay
here I'm starting to develop a good vibe
here at the motel goodbye I'm sorry the
folks with the food supply panty fences
didn't tickle your pretty pink ass yeah
don't tickle my we really think like a
healthly this affects everyone then we
vote if everyone agrees then we'll send
you come on what was the point of
letting to choose they will stay in this
wretched roach motel with your
recreational paperweight over there plus
we stay close to making where we have
access to the pharmacy for dad why is he
not holding a gun
gotcha what was he doing we go ah dad
you bet you pumpkin car you bet you put
ok so we go everyone is against me
they're offering food we gotta at least
check it out what about the good vibe
that we had here what do you think I
mean what do you think I'm very hungry
ok fine we'll go can't let my climbing
behind you go to a theory can't let Mike
let me go being hung there now can you
guys really have food sure do
we lost most of the cattle but we still
have lots of milk butter and cheese
stocked up and variables we grow we got
plenty of food they grow vegetable of
ease it's nice to get away from that
motel for a while this Lily Kenny thing
is starting to get ridiculous you should
tell me I'd be happier if you started to
take charge more ah
alright at least it won't be for later
shy thing everybody looks up to you
ya know that everyone thinks I'm so
trustworthy and no one cares great that
can't be easy
Clementine might know yeah I mean us
we're talking to the drugstore about
what we didn't exactly lie to her I
would never lie to Clemmy I don't really
know what happened to do what happened
I only know what the press was told I
don't know your story that's games I
wonder if I should talk to the group
about it you don't have you should
whatever happened before things went to
hell doesn't matter anymore I think your
vein would see it that way maybe you're
right listen over the years I've
reported on some pretty messed-up [ __ ]
I've seen situations like yours a
hundred times it doesn't have to make
you a bad man to kill someone else I
really appreciate that I want to know
his story I mean thank God Li Shu did
art rightly yeah why don't you tell us a
little more about yourself Lee where are
you from alright here's their chance
anyway I make love with Carly bar just
went up I grew up in Macon right here in
the heart of Java
well that's 50% now with Carly
pretty settled in at that motor in who's
running things over there is it sad
dialler you guys have any questions you
couldn't believe oh yeah
now we have 250 presenter he's like oh
yeah I'm gonna show my titties later
well we have enough to defend ourself in
droves well that's good getting
dangerous out there
well you guys know yeah well we'd love
to get you all out to the dairy like I
said we got plenty of food and quite
frankly we could always use an extra
helping hand right I used to help out on
a goat farm yeah that's great
everything helps yeah he looks like a
frog don't worry I got you covered if
something happens but let's just wait to
see that again
no these [ __ ] eyes are everywhere
come on let's get one Larry words sake
all right early in your [ __ ] eyes man
they just go everywhere it's [ __ ]
hilarious poor dude he died I didn't
notice I mean I know that's some into it
all right that's the tree yeah no sign
[Music]
there tis st. John family dairy alright
y'all can see how we kept this place so
safe fence keeps them out you bet him
they fry like bugs in a zapper listen
four thousand votes do that thing with
generators and amps
alright I'm going to assume that's a lot
oh you don't know Carly oh yeah she
sucks with second it goes that [ __ ]
radio wait I have to tell you know what
did I do okay
when you found the batteries for her
when I replayed everything and she put
them in the wrong direction is she I
don't know it's [ __ ] stupid all right
this place looks untouched
you never know the rest of the world is
in ruins it's worth protecting
it's all the juice y'all with company
coming down this here's Lee he's from
making it a couple of our old rubber
bands were from Macon they grow up good
there they got a few more friends
staying at the old motel Oh group why do
you give a [ __ ] alright I got this thing
I couldn't rather control over there
well I hope you know what you're doing
that place isn't safe like it is how
does she know that y'all were here we'll
make sure you're safe and comfortable
well we are all for hungry man awful
hungry these are for y'all baked fresh
is Noren how did you know that we were
coming can't get stuff like that anymore
not without a cow for milk and butter
that's for sure
that's right man yeah we'll make it
through this bout of whatever she's
gotten be with us for a good long while
we have no sorry n well we have a vet
yeah we can help you folks out Oh van oh
mama
our prayers have been answered
our group could come for the day wait I
don't like this y'all go get your
veterinary friend and I'll prepare some
dinner a big feast for all you hunger
she doesn't like chess writing yes they
have some folks to help out round here
again Danny why don't you come help me
out in the kitchen
why don't I head back with the food and
round up everyone for the trip over here
might wanna take someone with you
remember those roads can be damaged
China looks like me myself
take this why don't you go ahead and
take Ben along anyway take care of
yourself leave see in a while
all right I'm glad I saved Carly
actually more than I you know that I'm
Sprague nine rounds once you get settled
in I could use some help securing the
perimeter is there a problem
sometimes the dead get tangled up in the
fence now I will they fry and end up
knocking over a post it'd be a big help
if you could walk the perimeter all
right there's something about our fence
I'll be my own man generator and four
they run dry come get me when you're
ready
you betcha you betcha place is
incredible it's got food and that fence
man that fence if we want to [ __ ] that
don't check this might turn out to be a
place we can stay how do you want to
play this I don't know okay uh let's
make sure this faithful stay we can
think about bringing our whole group
here to stay
we need to figure out if this places are
safe as they're telling us right
obviously they think it's safe but is it
safe enough for the kids I noticed a
broken swing no sounds like a decent way
to get a good look at their defenses
it's good doing mark I'll keep my eyes
open and you find out what you can from
Andy all right okay so the thing is you
know the other girl let's pretend to be
the leader Lilly is their name I don't
really like her I know you can do like a
romance with her and
but I think Li fits better with Carly so
that's why I'm gonna try to pick them
together and that's why I prefer girls
all right what's up man I gotta talk to
this dude hi hi well I'm glad you guys
decided to help us out
I noticed back at the motel that you
folks are pretty well on then
stockpiling huh I guess you could say
that how much to get yeah that's a part
in the last few months about yourselves
what kind of protection do you have
around here we collected a few guns to
protect ourselves but we're really only
use them when we go off the property
and we're inside the perimeter of the
fences all we need to keep us safe good
find my man the fan of boxer defense is
enough to keep out walkers walkers is
that what you call him that's good the
old one wouldn't have but Mac he was our
Foreman he figured out how to amp it up
with the generators we used to sit out
here some nights and watch his sons a
big pop when they got too close that's
not a thing to Entertainment these days
I can imagine generators are enough to
power the whole Barry we got lots you
got to keep training for fuel as much as
we can but they all work together to do
the trick like us you can't always find
gas you know so we are your first yeah
the first people you've invited up to
the tear well no we've made similar
deals with other folks so trading for
gas and food but ultimately they moved
on looking for the people they lost
contact with hey guys I make sense
that's gonna fix it a crime in after you
with that perimeter now oh good defense
will stop a walker in about three or
four seconds but it's overloaded if we
leave the husks out there you know what
can I conclude offense ourselves if you
want to stay here and finish up with the
generators well that'd be great that'll
be fast food in fact it doesn't strip
them off and look for any weak points
well that'd be a big help
easy enough stay attend you never know
where's my man where'd my man Jesus
Christ this isn't so episode
oh well it's this how it is I guess it's
the same one we were in the farm the
other [ __ ] alright so how's the place
looking is a safe enough for us to stay
we can it's pretty amazing what they've
done with this dairy let's see what it
takes to secure this fence before
drawing any conclusions and wait till
everyone's out here everyone besides
Larry why the hell did you have to tell
him I thought he was a racist yeah
what's up with that
sorry man it just popped out yeah mark I
thought you were been a he's a piece of
[ __ ] Wow try to I try to be civil at
least yeah that's right Marv too busy
being cranky to notice yeah there's one
so birds and animals don't get affected
I don't get the deal with that yeah yeah
yeah it's dead yeah let's push it off I
don't really trust this what if Andy
said when this fence is working the
walkers go up like a tree branch on a
power line if those lights are out that
means the fence is off right better be
better be all right bro I'm pushing you
hey hey looks like you stuck
well it's probably because of this why
would you shoot him here rusty it's good
to do it my man
do it won't happen Harry yeah get out of
my way I'm sure there's still a few more
all right one second says patched up
this place will be a fortress God can
you imagine not having to worry about
the walkers anymore yeah well if that's
Matt gasps this without gas
we might need food but the st. John's
need gas - not many drivers these days
Lee we could scrounge up a year's worth
of gas easy so what's your take on the
brothers a year you have this place tied
down pretty well well we've got enough
people to take this place by force if we
have to
Shh Lee you sound like Kenny there's
another one I didn't really say that I
don't really mean sound like an [ __ ]
this is a point all right zombie let me
push ya it's never that easy is it god
damn it no it's my pants
that's what you get stay off my family
yeah
you never get used to the smell do you
sure smells like your mama's nope
nevermind Christ I can't stop thinking
about dinner
now after that the mountains earlier
it's not easy eating in front of the
kids
it's all that's keeping me on my feet
right now I'm hungry to work do you
think they're gonna be good for it
dinner for a whole group of people food
as they say I've I think so mm-hmm
that's the last of that one I think I
see where they're getting in this one
must have knocked it over trying to get
through he's tangled up in there pretty
good
come on help me get this thing back in
place so we can get mr. crispy off nice
the girls get better leverage from the
other side good idea that's not a good
idea bro something's gonna happen now
all right if you're waiting for that
kind of help it ain't gonna happen
come on he's not gonna help what am i
what am i oh okay Oh No
kkkk QQ QQ QQ what is it going on what
just happened I don't know Oh No I will
add a subset it alright anyway so it was
a really uneventful episode but I'm that
probably means something will happen now
anyway I can favorite EP night sky cover
birthday and I've seen it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] it